let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy happy
happy hump day
we are live
because it's wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
this
is
it and i
am the tony michaels
we have a lot of stuff to get to today
and we're not going to get to it all
i'm i'm i i assure you that we will not
get to every single topic
that needs to be ranted about
in this country
today in one hour
because there is so much stuff going on
and one of the things that i want to
talk about today is
the fact that we have a bill
that is supposed to build back this
country better
and
we have billionaires paying for captain
kirk to go into space and i'm not saying
that's a bad thing i'm not saying
william shatner should not go to space
that's not what i'm saying at all what
i'm saying is
is that we're arguing over
millionaires and billionaires
paying for the buildback better act
and all the while we're celebrating that
money going into space literally
just flushing it into space
uh one thing good about today though
some news about
government money is that social security
gets a raise today yay if i had a
sound effect of clapping i'd give you
some clapping
we also have so i want to talk about
those things uh we have the republicans
already teeing up their war on christmas
christmas is getting canceled
narrative it's already starting it's not
even halloween and we're talking about
how democrats want to cancel christmas
and the war on biden's war on christmas
i can already see the the fox graphics
already that he's not gonna let you get
your christmas presents
i got a clip for you to play
where jin saki's a reporter in the press
briefing over
uh a guaranteed christmas delivery holy
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] they're asking we
actually have uh a build back better
program that we're trying to get through
congress uh there's voting rights acts
that are trying to get through congress
the policing act the george floyd
policing act all kinds of
stuff that they can actually be asked
asking substantive questions on then
they're asking about uh the guarantee
of christmas gift delivery literally in
the white house that is their concern
holy
[ __ ]
um so the other thing i want to really
uh talk about today which
is uh kind of gotten shuffled under the
news with some of this stuff
is the trump organization some of the
trouble that they're in and some of the
announcements uh that have come out
about the
january 6th select committee and not
only not only how the trouble is going
to relate to the trump organization
with the select committee but also the
inaugural committee you remember the
trump inaugural money where did it go
and
and how his businesses are failing hmm
this seems like a pattern with this
orange buffoon
that his businesses and everything else
fail he's a [ __ ]
loser
like mary trump said he's a [ __ ]
loser he's a [ __ ] loser that's what
we should expect so i want to make sure
we go through some of those bullet
points
on how the trump organization is in
big hot [ __ ] water
so those are the topics that we're gonna
hit today
we're gonna hit those topics we're gonna
look at some tweety tweets about uh
about william shatner going up in
bezos's rocket
we're gonna watch a clip with jinsaki
about the christmas gifts and then we're
gonna talk about the trump organization
so hang on with me for this hour the
first thing i want to talk about is the
podcast here i appreciate all the
listeners out there liking retweeting
commenting even the trolls thank you for
all the hateful comments i i really do
like when you boost my post it's
fantastic thank you very much
but i want to say if you want to support
the podcast go to thetonymichaels.com
click on the merch store we have [ __ ]
stickers [ __ ] em cups we have [ __ ]
shirts uh [ __ ] pillows we got all
kinds of great stuff in there so if you
want to support the podcast go over
there to the
tonymichaels.com or
store.betonymichaels.com check out the
merch store all the proceeds go towards
the podcast all the fees of the the
fancy stuff you see and the fancy stuff
you hear and how we publish the podcast
so do that for me
please thank you now let's get into the
the topics of today uh william shatner
uh goes into space today and if you
watch the video it actually is a pretty
a touching video uh when he comes back
down and he's describing his experience
experience
that he just had where he was
sent into
space through earth's orbit and then
uh back down to earth and he describes
he's describing the point where he
actually breaks through the earth's
atmosphere and he's talking about the
sea of blue this flash of blue and then
you're in darkness
right um he's done this on tv shows
before of course but he's never done it
in real life so here is
on a rocket going into space
exiting earth
atmosphere and earth's orbit
and getting into space getting into zero
gravity and then coming back down to
earth but he's describing the moment and
it seems like to to to him
and the video of him describing it seems
like that moment where you actually
break the earth's atmosphere
is one of the uh the epiphanies you know
of the travel when you go that far not
very far but far enough to consider be
considered space
and he describes looking back down on
earth where there's life
and there's happiness
and then the the darkness of space he
says is that death that's what that's
what he asks is that death he kind of i
don't know if he's asking people around
him it's a rhetorical question if he's
asking himself they ask is that death
space the final frontier right
so we have jeff bezos loading captain
kirk
and a lot of people don't like that i
make fun of
besos's little rocket but it's a a
cosmic [ __ ] rocket it looks
come on it looks like a hitachi vibrator
some people are like oh all the space
shuttles and all the space things look
like built no no the space shuttles
the space shuttles look like airplanes
they did not look like weiners they did
not look like dildos they did not look
like the hitachi vibrator that you can
buy on amazon.com i don't know if that
was where jeff bezos got his inspiration
or if he was punked like someone's like
oh we're gonna have a design contest
and someone's like well we're gonna make
it look like a hitachi vibrator that'd
be funny
he'll never do that he did it he did it
100 looks like
an oversized giant hitachi vibrator it's
a space dildo that's what i called it
and my feeling is here's here's what i
want to get across with this message of
william shatner i am not against william
shatner going into space i'm not against
jeff bezos paying for william shatner go
in space i wouldn't even mind if all the
billionaires on earth got on one
[ __ ] rocket went into space and
never came back don't give to [ __ ]
but i will say
if jeff bezos can pay for william
shatner to go into space and to come
back into earth
then he can afford to [ __ ] pay taxes
that is what we can do we can tax the
rich here if they can afford at this
point if they can afford to shoot
oversized hitachi vibrators into space
with captain kirk on them
they can afford taxes
that is what the [ __ ] we need to do it's
enough enough of dancing around and
acting like oh you're gonna stifle
growth and you're gonna hurt capitalism
and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
if they can afford to do that kind of
[ __ ] then they can afford taxes
that's all i'm saying and i'm not saying
we should take all their money so they
can't have their little space dildo fun
time or whatever whatever it is that
they're doing with the space travel
because it sounds like to me that
they're wanting to create a way for rich
people to get off this planet and go
somewhere else to be you know the elite
somewhere else and the rich somewhere
else which is fine by me we just need to
take all their [ __ ] money before they
go
because we're the ones who gave them
that [ __ ] money it's our
infrastructure it's our system of
capitalism it's our system the
government that has made it to where
those [ __ ] have made the money
that they made
and giving them the money to shoot the
[ __ ] dildos into space
that is how it works
that is how it works
we do not need to redistribute the
wealth to the moon or to another planet
we got one right here and william
shatner describes it when he breaks
through the atmosphere that he looked
down and there is life
there it is right there in front of you
there's life and we're concerned about
the black space
of death
he says
william shatner that is
says
is it death he's talking about the
endlessness of space
that was his question when he reached
back down on the ground and he's he's
overwhelmed by emotion at this point
because this is actually pretty
incredible to see william shatner
captain kirk a person that we you know
in our minds has been the space and
lived in space right
to watch him
react to the actually leaving the
earth's atmosphere not
not in a hollywood movie set but in real
life
and realizing
how extraordinary that is
but also realizing the significance of
earth and everyone on and everything on
earth
and we're going to talk about climate
change a little bit here in a bit about
the build back better act
because that's part of it
and we just we just made it to where
jeff bezos can spend the money together
again i'm not against bezos sending
captain kirk into space fine if that's
what the [ __ ] you want to do with your
money whatever
whatever it just you don't get to keep
you don't get to keep all the money that
anyhow it's going to work
and anyhow we should do this
we should tax the [ __ ] rich
we should tax them
that
is how it should work
and one reason why um we should do this
is for that buildback better act
there's been a lot of let me let me show
you my tweet
on shatner so here's what i said if
william shatner can go to space then we
can tax the [ __ ] rich tax the rich i
i again i'm not saying william shatner
shouldn't go to space i'm just saying
just saying if we can get him to go to
space and jeff bezos can pay for him to
go to space then what we should do
what we should do is tax jeff bezos
because obviously he has enough [ __ ]
money
if he can send
captain kirk on the cosmic [ __ ]
rocket to go to space now uh don's non
winslow also tweet i want to show you
him he says hey world can we send the
for the people act to space with william
shatner so it gets the same [ __ ]
attention and priority let me know
the best
don winslow because i think that is the
thing here is that
we're paying attention
to
captain kirk william shatner going into
space he was trending at one number one
on twitter all day long almost all day
until
hashtag lauren bowmer lauren bobert is
so dumb started trending it went to
number one of course
but we can't figure out how to make sure
that the bill
build back better act
before the people act
all these important things
are trending
we need to get election reform
we need to get infrastructure we need to
get human infrastructure passed
we need to get the george ford policing
act passed
we need to kill the filibuster is what
we need to do
enough of this minority rule
[ __ ] democracy stuff the majority of
the country wants these things and we
need to pass them we have the majority
we formed a government it's time and
enough of this yapping about what the
numbers gonna be
with joe manchin and cinema and the
progressives enough of that [ __ ] who
cares what the [ __ ] number is no one
get no one gives a [ __ ] no one gives a
[ __ ]
no one gives two [ __ ] what the numbers
gonna be the only reason why we're
arguing about the [ __ ] number is
because this is a republican tactic
this is a republican tactic to get you
talk about the [ __ ] number so you
think that you're spending all kinds of
money that you don't have that's all
[ __ ] that's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
they spent they spent
tons of money on that on on tax breaks
for the rich
tons
tons of deficit money
trillions of dollars
on making sure that the rich got to keep
all their [ __ ] money and here we are
sending captain kirk into space with
jeff bezos money that he got to keep
because we decided that was a good idea
to run up the deficit that way to not
tax the wealthiest
in this country
but now now we gotta have this
conversation about how much the the
[ __ ] infrastructure bill is this
number that number it doesn't get it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
it doesn't matter what the number is who
gives to [ __ ] what the number is
what matters is what's in the bill and
what it's gonna do because here's the
thing the reason why the number doesn't
[ __ ] matter the reason why it doesn't
matter is because in the bill it's
[ __ ] paid for
it's [ __ ] paid for it's paid for by
taking their space dildo money that is
how we pay for it
that's how we pay for the infrastructure
that's how we pay for the human
infrastructure and if you want to see
what's in this bill i came up with the
graphic here it's not fantastic but i'll
tell you
there's two years free of community
college in the buildback better act this
is beyond
the physical infrastructure this is
beyond the the roads the bridges the
internet that we're going to get which
is going to
it's going to dump 1.1 trillion dollars
into the economy over the next several
years when they're building and
repairing the roads and bridges and
infrastructure in this country the
physical infrastructure
we have two years free of community
college
that's a that's incredible and the
reason why it's incredible we also have
child care and universal pre-k those two
components those two educational
components are something that we
desperately desperately need in this
country and if you don't think that we
desperately need
uh education in this country just run on
over to facebook
and look at the ivermectin institute
facebook groups that your uncle ned and
aunt sally's on go check out the
comments over there and you can tell me
whether we need some [ __ ] education
up in this son of a [ __ ]
because we hunter percent need some
[ __ ] education it's getting
absolutely ridiculous
and it all starts with making sure that
children are off on the right foot you
know using critical thinking and logic
and to continue that with when they
leave high school to make sure that they
can enter into the economy in the
workforce
with possibly a a degree from a
community college at the bare minimum
and i i i
not just saying community college
but also trade schools because we need
trades too
but this is all part of that this is all
part of making sure that our population
isn't [ __ ] dumb like lauren bobert
hashtag lauren bobert is so [ __ ] dumb
and that's what we get
that's what we get when we don't have
child care and universal pre-k pre-k
preschool
and two free years of community college
to make sure people you know got some
goddamn brains
the other thing that it does is medicare
expansion
oh well we're going to talk about social
security here in just a bit and how it
got a raise
this expands medicaid medicare now
there's some debate over the medicare
because oh joe manchin wants to go ahead
and make it solvent before we expand it
to vision and dental well let's do it
both at the same [ __ ] time
dummy stop arguing over the goddamn
number who gives a [ __ ] what the number
is it doesn't matter what the number is
it doesn't [ __ ] matter and the reason
why it doesn't matter is because we are
going to tax the rich
i'll give you an example here in a
minute i'll tell you exactly how what
the plan on that is
the democrats want to extend the child
tax credit this is that monthly amount
that's going into your account every
month if you have children
uh some it's 250 some it's 300 per child
and it's up to a certain amount and you
have to make under a certain amount of
money rather you're a household of two
or household of one
but the extended tax child tax credit
they want to extend that to 2025.
so all the people out there that are
receiving this tax credit into their
bank account every month
they're gonna this bill will extend it
to 2025.
boy with ever all these republicans
including kevin mccarthy bitching and
moaning and complaining about inflation
i wonder what could help families that
have children with inflation hmm i
wonder what could help that after we're
trying to struggle to get along here
with inflation after the pandemic
because it won't [ __ ] end because you
people won't do what the [ __ ] you're
supposed to do
which is end it and go get vaccinated
the next thing that it does is cut
prescription drug prices i'm not you
don't even have to go any further than
that
how how the [ __ ] can we disagree on
cutting prescription drug prices at this
point
is this even a [ __ ] disagreement is
this the thing that they're debating
back and forth between each other who
gives a [ __ ] how much it cost
no one gives a [ __ ] how much it cost the
reason why no one should give a [ __ ] how
much it cost is because it's costing the
american people nothing
besides besides the top tax rates that's
the only people that it's gonna cost any
money to anybody
that's it it's not going to cost the
working average family any [ __ ] money
none
speaking of
working families it's also going to get
paid family and medical leave
12 weeks a paid family and medical leave
so people can when they have a [ __ ]
baby you pro-lifers out there
they really are pro-life aren't they oh
as george carlin says when you're in
when you're in the fetus
we're all for you
but when you're born you're [ __ ]
12 weeks of paid family and medical
leave paid
do you hear that it's [ __ ] paid not
unpaid you don't have to build up your
vacation
you don't have to do any of that it's
paid
so that when that life comes into the
world you can make sure
that you give the first 12 weeks of that
life
that baby you pro-lifers who love to
clamor on and on and on
about this [ __ ] until they until till
they're born then you don't want
anything to do with those [ __ ]
12 weeks of paid family and medical
leave
and then it has provisions to combat
climate change which
here we are back to the william shatner
thing when he looks down on earth and he
realizes that that is the life
that's the lifeblood that's why we live
that's why we're here that's why jeff
bezos can build an oversized hitachi
vibrator and
send captain kirk into space
it's because we have life on earth
and it's precious
and we don't have much time
so there
those are the things that are in the
build back better act
but let's talk about let's talk about
how these things are [ __ ] paid for
because i'm [ __ ] i'm for one and sick
and [ __ ] tired of hearing
about how it's gonna be paid for and the
amount of money who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't matter what
the [ __ ] number is number one it's
over a 10-year period so this idea that
somehow the american people are gonna
shell out three and a half trillion two
and a half trillion one point one
trillion whatever the [ __ ] number is
[ __ ] all [ __ ]
because it's not like joe biden's just
gonna write a three and a half trillion
dollar check you stupid [ __ ]
it's over a 10-year period
whatever the number ends up being i
don't care if it's 10 trillion don't
give two [ __ ] here's why i don't give a
[ __ ]
because inside the buildback better act
you know what it does it raises
corporate tax rates by five measly
points
five measly points and my guess is that
they're going to try to find all kinds
of loopholes to get out of it because
also in the buildback better act
it gives the government funds
to make sure that those tax rates are
enforced by the irs
to make sure that they're not skating on
it you know you know committing tax
fraud like
uh you know something like a cheeto dust
mobster or grandpa poopy pants or
something like that you know
i'm sure we won't find out of any
attacks we're going to talk about that
here in a little bit uh
trump organization tax fraud we're going
to talk about that here in a little bit
but the corporate tax rate is going to
go up five percent five measly points
if you make under four hundred thousand
dollars a year under four hundred
thousand
if you make under four hundred thousand
000 a year
it's going to go up 2.6 measly points
2.6 measly points and that's going to
pay for all of this all of it
all of it the roads the bridges
the the pre-k the community college the
medicare expansion
all of it
the climate change part of the bill the
prescription lowering the prescription
drug cost
so if you make over hundred thousand
dollars a year number one
congratulations
but yeah you will have to pay a little
more if you make over four hundred
thousand you'll have to pay just to
smidge more just a smidge just a smidge
to make sure that everyone in this
country
gets all those things that we have
actually have some [ __ ] human
infrastructure and some investment some
real
life investment into working class
people and the human infrastructure of
the american people
the next thing that it pays for here's
the next thing we got more money because
it does and then again it doesn't
[ __ ] matter how much money it does
not matter it doesn't matter because the
capital gains rates are going to go up
by five measly points
so all those people that avoid
actual being taxed income taxed
because they avoid income tax because
their majority of their income is from
capital gains and nope you don't get the
slide anymore
we're gonna put five more points five
measly more points
people in the 1960s and 1970s the tax
rate was 70 [ __ ] percent
up until the late 80s it was 50 [ __ ]
percent
we're down into the low 20s the actual
attack rates down
just above 10 sometimes below 10 of the
actual tax rates after deductions and
all loopholes that they get
70
in the 1960s and 1970s
that was the high tax rate that was the
highest tax rate
70
percent
we can afford this stuff we've always
been able to afford this stuff
always
we just been affording
millionaires billionaires and
trillionaires
the ability to build oversized rockets
oversized dildo rockets to launch them
into space
and to
try to come up with some way to colonize
some other planet or a moon or something
well we have colonization here
and if you're pro-life
and you're not for this bill you're not
[ __ ] pro-life
i guaran guarantee you that
garen god damn to you that
so let's stop talking about the [ __ ]
money who gives a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
money is
who gives to
[ __ ]
no one gives a [ __ ]
no one should give a [ __ ] and the reason
why you shouldn't give a [ __ ] because in
the bill the rich pay for the
[ __ ] and they should [ __ ] pay
for the [ __ ] tax the rich
tax them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
the only reason why they got the money
in the first place is because it's ours
we gave it to them
and if they can afford again if they can
afford space rockets space space dildo
rockets
they can afford to be taxed
an extra five percent
oh five measly percent
it's enough of the arguing about it
the important thing is what's in this
bill not just the infrastructure bill
again
that infrastructure bill is going to pay
for real [ __ ]
tangible things road bridges internet
that all these rich people all the
corporations
they're the ones that use the son of a
[ __ ] they're the ones that make all the
[ __ ] money that we're gonna tax off
of that [ __ ] investment into
infrastructure
the [ __ ] roads the [ __ ] bridges
the [ __ ] internet you don't think
they're gonna benefit from that
get the [ __ ] out of here
get get the [ __ ] out of here shut the
actual [ __ ] up
corporations and the wealthiest in this
country benefit more from the physical
infrastructure than anyone else
and they make more profit off that
physical infrastructure than anyone else
and that's why they don't give a [ __ ]
what kind of shape it's in they don't
give a [ __ ]
why why would they give a [ __ ] they only
care they only care about their money
their profits so you know [ __ ]
if we have to pay five less percent to
have a shitty infrastructure we still
get to make the money right we still get
the profit
not in this country
because it's we the people
and we get to tell you hey hey
you can use the infrastructure you get
to use it
but you got to pay for it
you got to pay for it because we all pay
for it in most states there's a goddamn
gas tax there's goddamn toll roads
so the people actually driving on there
driving on roads paying the gas they pay
for it too and the federal government
should sling in money
to make sure that states have
infrastructure
rather it be cities towns rural areas
with it with internet that's the other
thing
jesus christ
we're gonna have high-speed internet in
rural areas
it'll be the first time
since the invention of the internet
since al gore invented it
i mean since he came up with it you know
he boom the idea popped in his head yeah
we should have the interwebs the
interwebs
now i'm making fun of al gore
the the first since the first time alcor
thought of the internet thought it up
we're actually going to have internet
high speed internet in rural areas we're
going to bring the entire digital world
to rural areas
maybe maybe maybe we can get in the
truth i doubt it with social media
but maybe we can get some truth into
those areas
when the high-speed internet reaches
the farthest reaches
of america
but the buildback
better act needs to not be about the
amount who gives a [ __ ] progressives
stop stop
stop fighting over it it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what the number is
don't give two [ __ ]
don't care mansion
cinema
don't give two [ __ ] because republicans
don't care about this thing at all not
only do they not give a [ __ ] about the
money they don't give a [ __ ] about
what's in it like they literally don't
give a [ __ ] about the stuff that's in it
they don't want to do that stuff that's
in it
that stuff that's in it god damn that's
gonna cost their corporate donors and
their rich donors to have more tax
we don't want american people we don't
want average working people to get those
things that might cost our donors money
god damn we can't have that
stop talking about the [ __ ] money
no one that is going to receive benefits
from this bill gives two shits about the
ending dollar amount
don't give a [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ]
all right so let's move on to the social
security because this has to do
with also people getting their fair
share in this country social security
social security's getting a 5.9 uh
percent raise
the largest raise in 39 [ __ ] years in
this country
how the [ __ ] is that even possible
that we went 39 years without having
something over a 5 raise holy [ __ ] this
is so ridiculous now you have you have
republicans and the right wingers and
the q and honors and the gqp
and kevin mccarthy that [ __ ] [ __ ] bag
i think we should get a subpoena and
we're going to talk about u.s marshals
here in a little bit i think kevin
mccarthy might be nervous that the u.s
marshals are going to give him a little
visit maybe here soon
but kevin mccarthy is
yammering on and tweeting about
inflation what do you think the social
security raises what do you think that's
for
what what do you think it's for
what do you think we raise the social
security amount in anyways four
why would we do that for inflation
oh
so thanks biden
thanks a lot
5.9
the largest raise in 39 years on the
social security
that we've had now a lot of people are
complaining that oh they'll take it away
in the medicare which frankly
part of that's true
now there is a percentage rate it's not
a
specific dollar amount on the social
security check so it's not like oh
you're getting an extra hundred bucks
it's a percentage but when you pay for
medicare part b the doctor's part of
medicare that's the government health
insurance
you have to pay for that which i don't
know why we've already paid for it
social security and medicare not
entitlements
listen republicans
social security and medicare are not
[ __ ] entitlements
they're not entitlements entitlements
the [ __ ] that you get that you didn't
pay for that you're entitled to
social security and medicare you paid
for that
to receive social security you have to
pay for social security
you have to actually work so many
quarters you have to qualify to get paid
social security you got to pay in to get
in right
that's the whole point
because what what the social contract is
with the federal government we the
people
the contract is hey you work you be
productive you pay taxes you make a
living you go out there and spend your
money into the economy
we'll tax a little bit of it but when
you get older and you can't work or if
you get disabled and you can't work what
we'll do is we'll make sure you have an
income oh and by the way when the
economy inflates and cost inflates we'll
go ahead and put inflation in there as
well
even though you made an amount of paid
as much as you'll get out the point is
is that the federal government is there
for your safety net to make sure you're
not [ __ ] broke because you can't work
either you're older or
you're disabled
you got it
that's the social contract
social security is not an entitlement
you pay into it
medicare is not an entitlement you pay
into it if if you [ __ ] if you [ __ ]
go look at your w-2 go grab it out of
the well it's probably on your email
right now but as you say go grab it out
of the build drawer everyone's got a
bill drawer don't they they got a drawer
that they put all their bills in
checkbook all that kind of [ __ ] pens
stamps
envelopes you got a drawer right you got
the junk drawer and you got the bill
drawer all the bills go in there paid or
unpaid hopefully the big ones get unpaid
on the bottom right
and maybe they'll surface their way to
the top if you have enough money to pay
for them with the social security
increase
that's what real americans worry about
not about how [ __ ] much the goddamn
buildback better act is going to be
rather it's three and a half two and a
half trillion average americans don't
give a [ __ ] about that they want to know
what the [ __ ] is going to be in it
and it's paid for it is paid for and
they now they know what's in it
but medicare and social security are not
entitlements you pay for those we pay
we pay a tax
we pay a [ __ ] tax
they're ours it's our money it's our
[ __ ]
it's ours and if you're worried about
solvency solve the [ __ ] problem
solve the [ __ ] problem
it's real easy solve the problem tax the
rich get the [ __ ] money
it's really easy
i know that it sounds sounds complicated
but it's not
it's not
and it's even more frustrating when when
we're trying to figure out
how to build back better this country
with things like pre-k
education
universal child care
medicare expansion
for
dental
and vision
reducing prescription drug cost
having two years community college so we
have people that grow up to be [ __ ]
to have an education in this country
so we can stop the [ __ ] buffoonery
whether it be a trade school or a real
[ __ ] uh uh a community college or
they're getting a degree in business
or technology something
we have reporters
we have reporters in the white house
asking the administration jinsaki
to guarantee that christmas presents are
going to be delivered what the [ __ ]
this is this is what they're asking i'm
dead serious this happened today they're
asking the administration to guarantee
that christmas presents are delivered by
christmas this is the [ __ ] that we gotta
[ __ ] deal with this is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is the questions that they
[ __ ] ask let me show you the clip
we can go ahead let me ask that a
slightly similar but different way sure
based on everything being announced
today yeah
and
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce uh delays
to ensure that we are uh addressing
bottlenecks in the system including uh
ports and the the need for them to be
open longer hours so that goods can
arrive and we can continue to press
not only workers and unions but also
companies to take as many steps as they
can to reduce these delays
so there you have it
uh
we seriously are living in a
a reality of where we're at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life because these are the questions
that have to be asked if the
administration is going to guarantee
that people are going to get their
[ __ ] christmas packages and here's
what this is
here's this is all distraction politics
and they're starting to roll this ball
down the hill this is all right wing
[ __ ] that is jimming up this conference
conversation
of christmas packages being on time and
the administration guaranteeing them as
if it's gonna be joe biden's fault that
christmas dis gifts didn't get to your
under your christmas tree in time
maybe he'll put on a red suit and get in
a sleigh with his tiny little reindeer
and go deliver him himself you people
are out of your [ __ ] minds
you've lost it
this is not
oh [ __ ]
you're gonna make the administration
stand and guarantee that christmas
packages are gonna be delivered because
here's what this is
this is the right wing rolling this ball
down the hill of oh cancel culture on
christmas you're going to cancel
christmas war on christmas you're going
to see it on fox news ah they're not
going to let our these ships are off sea
and they're holding these ships off sea
so they can cancel christmas and there's
a war on christmas joe biden doesn't
want there to be christmas you people
are [ __ ] stupid it's not even
halloween yet
if you want your christmas presents to
be on time go buy them now
if you if if you don't and here's here's
how i know here's how i know this is a
right-wing thing it's because they're
they're making it about christmas
they're not
they're not saying like what's gonna
happen if people can't eat during
christmas what happens during the
holidays we still have thousands and
thousands of people in the hospital with
covid are people getting sick because of
covid how are we gonna
are those families are what are those
families gonna do
what are we gonna do if people can't
afford to to
give themselves a christmas meal or a
holiday meal what are we going to do
nope it's about the [ __ ] gifts
it's about the presents
that's how i know it's a right wing [ __ ]
because that's what they concentrate on
that's the whole [ __ ] thing i mean
jesus christ they run around oh my god i
can't i can't go to work because i ain't
got a vaccine i can't get on an airplane
i can't go in a concert yeah that's your
choice it's your choice you're making a
choice not to get vaccinated so you
can't do that kind of [ __ ]
and they don't understand they don't
understand actual real choice in this
country they think their choices are
they have 33 choices of flavors at
baskin robbins that's their that's their
idea of choices and liberty and freedom
that they can go to the grocery store
and there's oh god there's there's 50
different frozen pizzas woohoo freedom
freedom liberty and rights
that's not that's not freedom or liberty
to choose tony's pizza
it's a good brand
i don't know if it has to do with the
name or not
but to choose tony's maybe red barons i
don't know
to choose those over any other because
you got the liberty to choose what
frozen pizza you want that is not your
actual choices that's not it that's not
liberty that's that's not it
that's not that's not it
it's not your liberty to receive
christmas gifts at a certain day and
time
maybe a certain amount of planning will
get you there
but the administration and the federal
government cannot guarantee that you're
going to get a certain gift on a certain
day
what the [ __ ] and really honestly if you
people are so [ __ ] worried about
packages getting delivered maybe you
should go with the united states postal
service and question dejoy and figure
out why he's not de fired yet
or arrested
in the jail
maybe maybe that's who you should ask
the questions to
is the [ __ ] government
the part of the government that delivers
packages
not not the white house if they're gonna
guarantee
get the [ __ ] out of here
this is this this and this kind of stuff
this nonsense this war on christmas [ __ ]
that they're gonna do this is what
they're gonna do
i i already know it i i can already tell
we're not even halloween yet and they're
starting this war on christmas joe
biden's gonna cancel christmas [ __ ]
with this they're not gonna guaran he's
not gonna guarantee they're gonna be on
foxes tonight
did you hear ginsaki's not gonna
guarantee that your christmas gifts are
gonna be delivered tucker carlson cue it
up
cue up the [ __ ] clip it's gonna be
there
it's a war on christmas they won't
guarantee your christmas packages are
delivered
it's already gonna happen tonight it'll
start to happen
they're gonna start rolling this ball
down the hill that joe biden is the
grinch
and it's to distract
from the trump organization being in so
much trouble and the select committee
laying down the hammer
if you haven't heard this news the trump
organization is in serious financial
trouble
they're trying to sell the lease to the
the dc hotel the trump hotel in dc you
know the one he laundered money through
the entire time he was president
now he has to sell the son of a [ __ ]
for like i don't know 370 390 million
dollars he not the hotel he doesn't own
the [ __ ] building that's what
everyone doesn't get about this
[ __ ] he doesn't own that
building the federal government owns
that building he just leases it to put
his name on it that's it
he just leased the building from the
federal government
which you know in the emoluments clause
we should really [ __ ] cut that [ __ ]
out
we should really hammer him on how he
launder money through the dc hotel and
maybe that'll end up in a federal court
somewhere who knows civil or criminal
but they want to sell it now now that
he's not president
and it's not easy for him to trade
favors for people who go to the dc hotel
i'm just assuming
you know launder money through that
thing possibly
now he wants to get rid of it it
couldn't be that it lost 70 million
dollars i'm sure that's not it
i'm sure that they didn't rob the money
out of it like he robbed his casinos
back in the late 80s early 90s
because he's a shitty business person
listen
he played a business person on tv he's
not actually won
and it's more clear now than ever when
they have to sell the lease to the dc
hotel because they laundered all the
money out of it
it's losing millions
the other trouble that the trump
organization in it appears is with the
inauguration committee and where all
that [ __ ] money went it appears that
ivanka trump somehow stuffs money in her
pocket and the trump organization's
pocket i wonder i wonder if the
manhattan da's
investigation has anything to do with
alan weisselberg and the trump
organization funneling inauguration
money into the trump org
and where it went to i wonder if that
has anything to do with it you know we
heard that we were supposed to have some
more indictments maybe just maybe where
he'll hear the words inaugural committee
because there's another federal
indictment that has to do with the 2016
campaign and another indictment that
possibly has that looks like it could do
with the inaugural committee
the tom barrett case the tom barrett
indictment
he was he was part of the inaugural
committee he was taking foreign money
for something else but it appears that
there was a relationship there it's kind
of funny how the the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa's poopy pants his first trip
was just to the saudis
that was his first foreign trip
and maybe maybe just maybe it was a
favor kind of like the favor that was
given when jesse benton took a hundred
thousand dollars and funneled russian
money into the 2016 trump campaign
and now he's under federal indictment
for [ __ ] for for funneling illegal
foreign money
to make sure that a russian got a
meeting with trump in a campaign
fundraiser
these things all seem familiar
i'm not sure what one thing that is in
common with all these things but it
seems like there's one thing or one fat
slob
that is in common with all these [ __ ]
things
which makes me believe that the trump
organization is going down like a fresh
cut tree
not to mention
not to mention
we have the select committee
and we'll get to that
about the us marshals meadows patel
scavino
and bannon here in a second
but there's one other thing about the
trump organization that a lot of people
are really worried about and that is
crew brought it up the group crew is
campaigning to get all the federal
contracts canceled
because of their criminal indictment the
trump organization is under criminal
indictment in new york state it is not
civil indictment
they are not being investigated they are
criminally charged
are you [ __ ] people paying attention
the guy who thinks he's gonna run for
the president in 2024 on the republican
the gqp ticket
the company that he's owned and ran for
decades and decades and decades and
laundered money and probably gonna get
charged with more tax fraud and more
people are going to be brought into this
indictment with the manhattan d.a in the
state of new york
is under criminal indictment
there being accused of crimes
you got it
the former president of the united
states
the mango mussolini jesus
the gqp front runner of the
2024 presidential campaign who continues
to go rally because he's irrelevant
because he can't manage to conjure up
any kind of following without a rally
without his minions
all all of his concert
groupies coming and standing behind him
the same [ __ ] people it's the same
[ __ ] people have you watched this you
go to the rallies you look at the videos
it's the same [ __ ] behind him
it's the same they just they just kind
of shuffle them around it's same
[ __ ]
that are behind that some [ __ ]
the same [ __ ] people in the crowd
same exact people
it's like you know 2 000 people same
[ __ ] same [ __ ] all
going to the same spot and they gather
up a few local groupies but it's all the
same groupies going to one spot same of
others
but the trump organization
the business that the the former
president and his children
which his children were part of the
government
they were part of the trump
administration
that company is under criminal
indictment
as well as its cfo its chief financial
officer alan weisselberg
and it seems it seems as if there's
trump inaugural money missing
hmm
and it seems as if it was funneled
through the trump organization who's
criminally indicted
and it seems as if
with two indictments with
barrick
tom barrack and the jesse benton diamond
it really seems like those have to do
with the trump campaign
it's not hard to follow the [ __ ]
bouncing ball here
it really is not difficult
now we are counting on the department of
justice and merit garland to do their
jobs but it's gonna take some time
because the one thing that the select
committee
and even the prosecutors are worried
about is the trump chaos machine because
he's continuing to stoke
chaos continuing continuing to snow
chaos and then they're stoking chaos
with vaccine mandates and mask mandates
and
they keep on with this stuff i mean even
jim jordan is is talking about how they
they need to ban all mandate vaccine
mandates in ohio polio and all of them
for everyone what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
and the reason why they're getting
they're they're starting to evolve from
covet vaccine bad to all vaccines are
bad is because
it is the evidence is gonna bear out
that vaccine mandates work and when you
do vaccine mandates people get
vaccinated and when people get
vaccinated we won't have the problem
that we have with kovid and when the
pandemic is over they don't have this
wedge issue why do you think they want
to continue the pandemic they want to
continue it as a wedge issue because
they want trumpism fascism and a maga
hat to continue and the only way to do
that is to divide up america and the
easiest way to divide up america right
now is old big bad scary government you
know in the form of private companies
developing vaccines to help you save
your life from a deadly pathogen that we
all know about now you know that thing
where private companies are actually
doing it and the government's
encouraging it and matter of fact
they'll even pay for it for you to get
it because they don't want you to get
sick and spend all kinds of money on
health care because that's what the
federal federal government is doing
without you doing it and the economy's
suffering you know that type of [ __ ]
yeah okay
they want the pandemic to continue
so the plan is is to continue this road
down vaccine mandates all of them are
bad
because
they're they're up against a wall here
of the vaccine mandate because people
are starting to get their job they're
starting to lose their [ __ ] job
starting to lose their positions
and they're up against these vaccine
mandates and republicans know they work
it's
historical data proves it out
they work they work they work they've
always worked to continue to work and
they're going to continue to work my
disappointment is is that we didn't do
this [ __ ] sooner we should have done it
six months ago [ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
you don't want to get vaccinated fine
stay the [ __ ] home you don't get to
have a job you don't get to get on an
airplane you don't get on a bus you
don't get on a train fine [ __ ] you you
don't get to do anything the rest of us
did that [ __ ] all all 2020 and you
[ __ ] did whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted to do and you spread around
coveted you [ __ ] killed hundreds of
thousands of people and you continue to
kill a hundred thousands of people
because you're [ __ ] selfish because
that's who you are that's who you are
conservatives fascists in this country
are [ __ ] selfish evangelicals
self-proclaimed christians are [ __ ]
selfish they don't believe a single word
that [ __ ] book says not a [ __ ]
word never have never will
and we see that by giving him a pass
with the select committee they're all
cheering steve bannon meadows and patel
and scovino to skip out on these
subpoenas as if the the law and order
party in this country
that would be their message
and today liz cheney and others on the
committee say no we will use the full
force of the u.s marshals to enforce
these subpoenas
so
my suggestion is the us marshals need to
go look in all the trash dump dumpsters
for steve bannon because he's going to
be hiding same way as scavino because
apparently it looks like it seems that
mark meadows and patel are actually
cooperating
uh oh
mark meadows is cooperating
i even said it last week there's the
squeeze you want the squeeze squeeze
mark meadows the former congressman the
chief of staff he was right there he was
there the whole time he knows everything
that trump knows
everything all of it
he's the guy with everything to lose
squeeze that [ __ ] [ __ ] him
and there's gonna be criminal
indictments everywhere here
so why would mark meadows or any of
these people want to risk a criminal and
a criminal referral to the doj
why not cooperate now with the select
committee let the evidence bear out so
that maybe maybe maybe just maybe they
don't have a chance of a criminal
referral
but it looks like
it looks like the select committee is
gonna have to use the us marshal service
to enforce these subpoenas
because what the hell good is a subpoena
to anybody if they're not going to
enforce it
i mean if they don't enforce these
subpoenas for the federal crimes that
these poss these people have possibly
committed or the evidence of federal
crimes that anyone else has committed
the cheeto dust mobster
kind of funny how all the select
committees
stuff comes back to one person
because the real get here is gonna be to
have eastman giuliani and mike pence
testify
and ultimately
grandpa poopypants
i would love for nothing more than to
watch the us marshalls haul his ass in
the room to where he has to sit down for
11 hours like the email lady did
and be under the bright light of the
committee
questioning for 11 hours
well you can't do it you [ __ ] wimp
huh you're gonna puss out the email lady
did it
she did it with style class
and she buried your republican select
committee against benghazi because the
committee wasn't it was not a
fact-finding mission for benghazi
and what happened it was a fact-finding
mission of how to bury hillary clinton
and she still did it anyways
even kevin mccarthy said it which i
think that should be another subpoena i
really want to watch i really want to
watch a select committee question kevin
mccarthy about his phone conversation
with the president
the same way as some of these other
congress people jim jordan jim i don't
report sex crimes jordan you
[ __ ]
yep
there's another subpoena that we need to
enforce won't be hard to find that son
of a [ __ ] he'll be in some fox news
studios somewhere yelling and screaming
at a fox news
camera the other congress people that
need to be
put under a microscope with subpoenas
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert and
matt gatz
all of them
every one of them
ted cruz josh hawley all of them
they were obviously in on this eastman
plan
tommy tuberville you know the east
eastman memo
professor eastman
who laid out the plan for grandpa
pooping vance to commit his cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
in the oval office
there's another [ __ ] needs to be
in her subpoena
eastman
we want to hear why he wrote the memo
when he wrote the memo and what the memo
was for
why did you lay out a plan to overthrow
the government of the united states
to subvert the united states
constitution to convince the vice
president of president united states
that they could in one fell swoop be
dictators of this country huh
why was that
you know better than that why would that
be why did you write that
did you know it would convince someone
of something that's not true
i think so get eastman subpoena that son
of a [ __ ] and i think we should use the
full force the
u.s marshal
send them out
get them there we're at day five almost
it's time there's a day five deadline
coming up and they sh they should start
slapping cuffs on these son of a [ __ ]
enforce the subpoenas
now
we want answers
and this should not distract from the
buildback better act
and the only distraction from the
buildback better act again is the amount
of money an argument over the amount of
money shut the [ __ ] up progressives and
cinema and mansion shut up about the
money talk about what the [ __ ] it does
for the american people
democrats really need to figure out how
to sell stuff they really do it's not
about the money the money's paid for it
the bill pays for itself right there it
pays for it 100 pays for it there's
there's no reason to talk about how much
money because it is no money it doesn't
cost it doesn't cost the average working
american any money not a goddamn cent
so just so just talk about what it does
for the american people that's what you
should do
and then next week join us again
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern again right here on
youtube twitter twitch
thanks for joining me today again go
check out the thetonymichaels.com
for all your merch to support the
podcast and before i forget one other
thing before i forget [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them